i thought this would be just a rumor
but it's happening dc fandom it's going
to be making up
so much of whatever lacked in comic-con
this year this event's gonna rock
my god my god guys a suicide squad video
game has been confirmed by rocksteady
here's a tweet from them target locked
dc
fandom august 22nd now
it's time to look at the actual poster
here we go
pretty dope simple but dope yeah
that's dope we got an article pulled up
here i want to read up
on this there's been so many different
kinds of batman games announced
rumored to be in development but i love
the idea of doing a suicide squad one
and
the fact that they have a target here
pointed at
superman's head this must be confirming
the rumor the suicide squad
is going to be going up against that's
right
the avengers homeland
the justice league oh boy so the creator
of the batman arkham games
um is behind this one but i can't
imagine it would be the same
thing at all because i was just like
batman you know yeah i think they would
want to vary it up especially if you've
got a
ensemble of characters exactly john i
like where your head's at my brother
rocksteady posted the poster on social
media noting a further announcement will
be coming at this month's dc
fandom virtual convention
that's gonna be a busy weekend for so
many people
back in june actually saw a suicide
squad versus justice league video game
rumored see i thought i thought that was
just a rumor that's not too good to be
true
as a list of registered domain names
from rocksteady oh my god
the idea like suicide squad versus the
justice league that's such a great idea
like my mind just started getting all
these flashes of images suicide squad
kills the justice league as well as
batman gotham knights what is also
interested is that both
jai courtney and joe jello
have seemingly teased involvement in a
video game as the pair have posted
images of themselves with mocap suits
and dots
which are often used to create likeness
of actors for video games oh so
what wait a minute so they're going to
be in it so joe manganiello is
doing his death stroke character i guess
and that means we get oh hell yeah
boomerang himself back too
good old jai court i mean he's gonna be
in the actual suicide squad okay
checking out the background we see they
filmed at the same location
so maybe the suicide squad video game is
in part based on the dc
eu hey i didn't even consider
that maybe they can get a will smith
deadshot
oh damn that's pretty cool if it has
some tie-ins or if
they're just doing some you know
honoring of
yeah that's good and jack courtney was
good let's bring him in here well it
seems to speak to the fact that these
people seem enthused to be there
yeah you know not every actor would turn
up to mo cap a video game version of
themselves
a suicide squad video game has actually
been in development for years as back in
2012 the highly beloved and notoriously
positive jeff johns teased the game
however it's guessed the new suicide
squad video game is something different
and new as that game was said to have
been
cancelled i mean to get rocksteady the
creators of the batman arkham games you
have me sold on that
alone it's crazy because you have like
this avengers game from the marvel camp
coming out
where you're going to be able to switch
around between the marvel characters so
you got a wish fulfillment there in the
in the marvel category and then in the
dc
arena i don't know i mean you say
rocksteady and the batman arkham games
under my mind immediately
i'm gonna edge i'm gonna egg on that dc
versus marvel war
because especially the video game sphere
i'm being so biased right now i'm being
incredibly biased and i'll admit it
because there's no footage of this game
there's zip but you tell me those two
things alone
rocksteady the creator of the batman
arkham games my mind goes
this game's gonna totally surpass that
avengers game
instantly goes there it seems a bit like
and that's funny because it seems like
dc
has a firmer grip perhaps on the video
games fear marvel
does have spider-man you know we're in
beta testing for that marvel avengers
game
and uh yeah i mean it would be cool to
see this lead to some kind of actual
clash of characters in the future but
this just sounds like a great idea
suicide squad taking the rogues gallery
it's almost like you have the batman
arkham games and now you get to
flip it to the other side and you're on
the villain team well if you remember in
the suicide squad movie so there's
something that i find kind of
adorable about it being linked in a
slight way to the
dc eu amanda waller says like what if
superman turns on us
you know we need a team that would do it
and then when you see the suicide squad
assembled in that particular movie
you're like what are these guys going to
do if superman turned on them right
why is everyone hawkeye or black widow
yeah well your mind can't
wrap your head around how it's possible
now we don't know what suicide
squad members will be involved in this
particular gang
uh however they're gonna bring it to
life with them having to go
up against the justice league i mean
there has to be them going up against
the justice league because
i mean this is freaking superman's head
right here yeah
if they aren't teasing that this is a
very very misleading poster
yeah and then you know like with the
batman arkham i've only played arkham
asylum
i started up arkham city but i i stopped
because i heard there's uh
possibly a trailer for jedi falling
order too coming out so i was like i
need to play that
i'm gonna try to at least beat arkham
city before
this whatever trailer comes out here
for uh for fandom yeah but i
i don't know if they'll have anything
really ready for it i feel like it'll
just be announcements and stuff because
it sounds like they've announced that
they're gonna be making this game unless
this is an
actual image not just concept art that
they really touched up to release for a
promo pic
it's hard for me to imagine that they
actually have a trailer ready to go
you know i mean maybe some kind of
teaser like it wouldn't be that hard i
would imagine to animate
some kind of teaser proof of concept or
something like that i feel like we'll
get a logo
yeah which is that yeah you can see that
yeah maybe some kind of very simple
animatic
based on this idea or maybe you'll get a
target on each of the justice
league members faces or something like
that and then a quick tease at who the
main core team you'll be playing as will
be or something yeah leaving a couple
spaces for mystery of like we're gonna
announce more characters down the line i
feel like
video games love to do that now too what
i'm hoping that they do with this
particular video game
is that a they really let you see
the justice league if they are going up
against them from the suicide squad's
perspective to the point where we
view the justice league as if they're
the bad guys
in this game you know but at the same
time i'm
hoping that they do enough uh character
storytelling and fleshing them out of
the suicide squad to the point where
they don't hold back on the villainous
ruthless side of the suicide squad
yeah kind of asking for a lot here i
wanted
i want him to be like major anti-heroes
and don't hold back on the villainous
side of the suicide squad but at the
same time let them be the protagonists
and let the justice league feel like the
villains of this story i mean i could
definitely see that happening from what
i've seen of the previous batman games
that they've developed and
and whatnot um it seems like they have a
nice
blend of you know some of the grittier
tones that the movies have brought in
but also keeping it
more jacked up and more comic book yes
like batman is
ripped in the game even though that is a
darker grittier game and so i
think this will leave them a lot of
territory to play with that in but yeah
i think the game still has that question
to answer of like okay
how are we going to identify with these
characters
against the people we know as heroes and
and how are they going to be powerful
enough to take on like a superman type
but yeah
if they really lock you into that
perspective and use this as an
opportunity maybe because storytelling
in games has gotten a lot more engaged
too as the years have gone on maybe to
do their own version of yeah
deconstructing the downsides of what the
justice league
is and maybe what the collateral damage
is and maybe giving you
certain bits of story with the suicide
squad members that make them a little
more sympathetic at the moment you know
or something like that i don't know
this seems like there's a lot of
potential here and it seems like they've
drawn a very direct line in the sand of
like no we're
gunning for the justice league in terms
of gameplay i'm really curious to see
what they do with their storytelling
department it's one thing that these
batman games
the games are really hail for their
storytelling going with the suicide
squad you can't only play
as one telling a newbie i would love it
if you just only play as amanda waller
where you have to read facial
expressions and like manipulate people
yeah it's all strategy you're gonna
probably be hopping around between these
different characters because in those
batman games and
you're just playing as batman while the
gameplay on that is a
total blast i'm excited to see all the
different types of with the different
characters you can infuse
the different types of skill sets you
can acquire throughout the game with
them or is it going to be
like you choose who you play as you know
i don't know what it's going to be
but i'm curious to see what they got in
store
that's my wrapping it up voice guys who
are you excited for this suicide squad
game leave your thoughts down below if
you like this idea
hit the like button subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell i'm gonna stress out this month as
i try to keep up with editing for
umbrella academy while also trying to
start the harley quinn show finish doing
patrol read some comic books get more
acquainted
with black cat it's gonna be a lot let's
see how much i could cram into the
noggin and see
how much i can retain by the time dc
fandom rolls around hey
mark leach mark leach our friend from
the uk
he wanted to upgrade to a patron of the
day exclusive
shout out well you got it here buddy
he's on our discord he loves chatting
with us
and he is i think the only
the only one the only one the one who
enjoyed whenever we would read facts
about doctor who on our doctor who
watch-alongs
our british accents for mark i say to
you
mark leach you're a lovely gentleman
i really appreciate having you here
thank you
so much for all your generosity
i love this support you gotta show us
you got a real
bright smile and a lovely presence about
you you bring such a lovely attitude
you're you're dialing it back oh and uh
sorry
it sounds started sounding natural and
you're
ruining it i i just can't you know i i
ruin everything
we're with authenticity